all right so we ended up unfortunately
it happens every once in a while a guess
that we're planning on having on cancels
last minute so we're gonna go to the
phones for a bit at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty and see
what is on a people's minds starting
with our caller from the five to zero
area code who's calling today from five
to zero
five to zero if you're muted unmute
yourself because we can't hear you I'm
sorry about that key give me now yes and
you're not on speaker are you no no okay
so if there's any background noise
what's going on um recently I've been
trying to understand more on economics
I'm completing you to politics and also
understanding economics and I thought it
would be a good idea to study the
writings of them Hamilton being that he
is you know the father of you know our
financial system here in the United
States but since I'm you I don't know
that's a good approach what do you
recommend are there any books that I
should study on American economics or
what's interesting about that is there
is often a misconception that the
American financial system and economic
theory have much more overlap than they
actually do and if you actually take a
look at it the financial system we have
is so political and so subjugated by the
political system that there's often very
little economics to be understood from
looking at our financial system you know
as an example most of the conversations
that are the important political debates
around taxation are not really debates
in the world of academic economics
academic economics has already figured
out how a lot of the things work that
our politicians continue to debate and
influence the financial system
regulation is another one in the
economic world the value and importance
of regulation is pretty widely
understood of course there are some
disagreements and you have extreme
libertarian economics but within the
political system this supposed debate
over whether you need some degree of
regulation in your financial system is a
massive political debate so I think that
there's not no
armed in understanding how our financial
system was created but I would look more
at basic economic textbooks and it's
important to understand even though I
don't agree with it as the primary world
view I think it's important to
understand traditional economics of
rational actors and perfectly free
markets just so you know what the
framework is but then you want to add to
that behavioral economics which combines
the psychology of how economic actors
actually behave to get a more
well-rounded understanding I don't have
any offhand I don't know which economics
books I would look at specifically but
I'm sure you can find good
recommendations online but focus more on
economics than the financial system
because the financial system is much
more a product of the political desires
of our elected officials than it is of
academic economics okay I also heard
this we always talk about capitalism and
socialism there is also this other thing
called the American school that Hamilton
was part of if not the founder of it is
there any real difference between that
you know system of thought in comparison
to capitalism or socialism I am yes it's
not the same but I'm not familiar enough
with it to be able to tell you offhand
the the sort of minutiae of the
differences really appreciate the call
though hope that glad you're getting
informed about this stuff No thank you
very much all right take care